hay una duda de la capacidad del centro
político brasileño de llegar a 22 con un
candidato que sea competitivo y aunque
muchos de los partidos de centro estén
intentando construir esa candidatura por
ejemplo por el gobernador ha deteriorado
del sur o por ejemplo con el gobernador
de sao paulo
tengo dudas de que será posible porque
estamos faltan 20 meses un poco menos
para las próximas elecciones pero este
es muy poco tiempo para para que se
consiga construir una medida fuera
competitiva y una vez que tenemos dos
candidatos muy fuertes a la izquierda de
la derecha el espacio el espacio pero la
papa para un candidato desde el centro
creo que no es no es tan posible como
fuera
hace años pasados
ahora tiene posibilidades reales lula de
llegar a la presidencia nuevamente o
puede ser castigado de todas maneras por
los escándalos de corrupción que salpica
en el partido de los trabajadores u
partidos
creo que sí porque la suprema corte en
esta semana confirmó que los procesos
del lugar tenían tuvieron vicios
jurídicos y sólo fueron básicamente dos
vicios jurídicos el primer vicio fue que
era la jurisdicción que él juzgó válvula
no no era la justica jurisdicción
competente para hacerlo y el segundo
vicio fue que el juez seco moro no actuó
con imparcialidad
entonces la suprema corte básicamente no
decidió que lula es es inocente porque
aún tendrá que pasar una vez más por un
juicio en una zona u otra en otro
tribunal pero a la suprema corte ha
decidido que duda podrá ser candidato en
22 entonces creo que la decisión será
ahora una decisión mucho más política
del ex presidente
yo la jurídica de las cortes brasileñas
ahora rápidamente para finalizar podemos
esperar que evolucionaron modere su
discurso de ultraderecha para atraer a
más votantes
pero no no creo que él lo hará porque
básicamente evolucionar tiene que
agarrar a los pocos que quiere que están
con ellos y los 30 por ciento de los
votantes entonces creo que no lo haga en
oro ahora y también no lo hará porque si
lo hace básicamente tendrá que hacerlo
por medio de la pandemia luego ya le he
modelando su discurso y no creo que
quiero a eso ahora